okay Mr Sanders recognized for five
minutes thank you very much mr. chairman
the issue that I want to pursue is a
very simple one and that is the federal
government and numerous states including
the state of Vermont mr. Crawford dr.
Crawford you and I chatted about this
very briefly yes and I discussed it with
secretary Thompson as well very briefly
they identified the feds in the states
have identified over 5 million flu
vaccine doses that are available in
canada and in europe and we are not
talking about obviously fly-by-night
companies we are talking about a ventas
we're talking about glaxo we're talking
about ID biomedical in Canada ah and to
the best of my knowledge these flu
vaccines have already been used and
distributed in Europe and in Canada's
but like a new product my question is
given the crisis that we face mrs.
Maloney mentioned the people in New York
already dying the fear is that there
could be a serious outbreak of flu why
does it take so long I mean you have
reputable companies in countries which
are well regulated Europe in Canada you
have a product which has already been
distributed to the people in those
countries why last month did you not
send a host of inspectors there to make
the check of the factory if you want of
the plant of the dosages and get them
out to the people dr. Crawford we won't
take very much longer the process is
basically threefold the dis max these
vaccines although used in other
countries and not approved for use in
the United States so we've got we've got
to speed up that process the way we do
it is we contacted these three
manufacturers got their their production
records and also their what's called
their master file of how they produce
the vets the first day and what did you
do on the second thing the second thing
is we sent inspectors and they have now
all completed their inspection of these
facilities they will file
the reports with me the first thing let
me I don't mean to be rude we don't have
a lot of time okay I understand all that
that's legitimate that's two days worth
of work why is it taking it a month no
it's about a month worth work why
because you've got to get these master
files you've got it first yeah you've
got to get the cooperation we have
things like email you have plain
chocolate let me explain you've got to
get the cooperation of the company they
first got a design is that they want to
give it to life talked we have talked in
Vermont to some of these companies they
want to sell their product you're not
giving me a good briefly wider certainly
yeah we've got to give them approval to
bring it in under what's called an
investigational new drug I'll give you
three days this does not take a month
you are people in my state were very
concerned all over this country they're
concerned I can assure you we get it as
quickly as we possibly can but you see I
think I want to raise a question and
tell me that maybe I'm being overly
concerned here some of us including
majority in the House believe in
prescription drug re-employ tation we
think that it is insane that Americans
have to pay to 35 times more for the
same product that our friends in Canada
and Europe do if we had prescription
drug re-employ tation those products
would be in this country a month ago I
hope very much the given the
administration's opposition to re-import
ation you're not making this more
difficult than it should be could you
comment on that if the question is are
we making it more difficult than it
should be the answer is no but you still
haven't given me a reason why with all
of the resources at the FDA's command
why we have not approved those medicines
and why we have not destructive toes you
been doing it as quickly as we can and
then it's a matter of days away before
we make a determination about these
particular products what does it take
you to make a determination well it
depends on what the data is we get how
we evaluate whether or not we can
explain to the people who are watching
this you have a product that has been
widely distributed in Europe and Canada
you're inspecting these facilities are
major drug companies aboveboard
reputable
what is the determine how long is the
determination going to take and why is
there some way it's written it's
variable it's normally about a month's
time before we reach an evaluation
because we've got to get all the records
we've got to visit the plant we've got
to make a determination we've got to be
sure that the vaccine brought in won't
injure the American of course by law it
has to be done on an investigational new
drug application and that's where it is
but once you how long is this
determination process going to take
that's just about over all right so you
think you can make a decision fairly
within a week I wouldn't be held to a
week but I think it's it could be
quicker than that in one case all right
now my question is and I know we you and
I chatter about us I talked with the sec
I'm to expire date is question quickly I
30 seconds to go to state the question
are you going to allow states and cities
to go forward or is this are these
european and canadian drugs are going to
come into the US and you guys will
distribute it we working with the state
some of them want to bring them in
directly and they already have made
contact so go so we'll work with them on
an individual case-by-case basis thank
you very much let me I could just follow
up on you are at this point I think you
testified earlier you you believe that
some of these drugs from foreign
manufacturers are going to be certified
be able to come in because somebody's
vaccine Jackson's right then thank you
very much I believe mrs. who's next
every mr. Tierney if you had questions
yet I think you were here were you like
five minutes we still have a couple
questions here thank you Jim dr.
Crawford's let me ask you a set of
questions here about Chiron's plan to
Liverpool England it was subject to
inspection both by the FDA and by the
British counterpart the MHRA you've
repeatedly stated that both agencies
responded to the august two thousand
four reports of contamination in a
similar fashion I think the committee's
october eight hearing you said that both
FDA and the MHRA performed inspections
that were about the same thing in a
later press conference with secretary
Thompson you stated we would have five
hours later made the same conclusions as
the British we were in synchrony
with them so I want to just ask about
some of the differences between the
British in the United States approach to
that August chyron announcement of
contamination when the initial
contamination was reported it was the
United States and not the UK that
immediately lost several million doses
it was the United States and not the UK
that was depending on Chiron for about
half of its vaccine supply yet it was
the British who had I think much less at
stake with this vaccine facility than
the United States that sent an
inspection team to the facility within a
few weeks of the August 25 announcement
and the British who also sent a second
inspection team to the plant at the end
of September why didn't our FDA respond
forcefully to the August contamination
by sending inspection inspectors to the
plants as did the British we had
inspectors in the plant and on August 25
and if I can just interrupt you had
somebody there by coincidence who was
inspecting an entirely separate and
discrete issue they were getting up a
different line and but they were there
and they were alerted by Chiron they
went over some records made some
recommendations subsequent to that we
and CDC arranged for a series of calls
at least once a week to find out how
they were doing with their bioburden in
that plant things appear to be going
well up until the final reports which
came to the British and also came to us
virtually the same amount of time they
schedule and in an inspection as did we
but your inspectors over there did not
do the same kind of thorough inspection
that the British team did when it went
in can't speak for the British but you
can speak for your eyes I mean you know
that they did have a more thorough
examination your person did a somewhat
cursory look at some records but didn't
actually have a full flown inspection
that you would know they would have had
a response to this type of an umbrella
see we would have come to the same
conclusion based on a lot release
program we would not have allowed the
product into circulation and I made that
decision following an inspection that
was taken plate that took place on site
now let me look at another point of
difference on this the British received
the draft of the chyron inspection
sometime in mid-september before even
their second inspection yet on the other
hand we never received the
pull it until the British actually shut
down the facility in sometime in October
how do you explain the fact that the
British got that inspection reports so
much more quickly than the FDA did we
were getting a weekly update from the
company and we were scheduled for the
final report on october five the the
chyron facility was under instruction
from the US government to quarantine the
product which they did so none of it
could be released based starting in
August 25 so I believe we had control
but I did have control because none of
it got out there was a something there's
a serious gap in the British seemed to
be on top of this thing they're getting
a report before their second inspection
we get it weeks later it seems to be
like there would be a lot more
aggressive well they had less at stake
than we did it and I'm wondering why it
was that we got a report every week but
the final report was scheduled for
october five for both governments
because that was the end of the run you
can't get a final report until they
finish well is it is it fair to say
though the FDA was caught a little
flat-footed about the British closing of
that plant that the fda didn't even know
was going to happen until after the
phone well by law they could not
communicate with us and we didn't we you
know and and we did not know that they
were going to do that on october five
know that is correct the law that you
measure is a british law it is right but
that can be waived we know that because
it was waived after the fact well
there's the british issued a press
statement about three days after the
october five determination which they
said they were constrained by their law
from communicating to us or the other
ninety eight countries and that really
could be waived and it was waived after
the fact well now we're able sharing
information out of the company's
willingness to share it as my question I
guess is this is very important source
of supply for us yes we had a lot at
stake why would we rely simply on the
company's analysis or report of fact or
whatever why hadn't we ask for a waiver
company which tells us now that they
would have certainly cooperated why
didn't we ask for information on more
than one source as this thing was
developing why not say to the company
ahead of time
and we need a waiver we want to not only
find out from you what's going on we
want to talk to our British counterparts
and we want to have our own inspections
we want to stay on top of this thing
because we have so much at stake we were
getting all the information we were
asking from there was no need to do that
thank you gentlemen at this time mr.
coming to you thank you very much mr.
chairman i really appreciated I